Hey!
Dr. Rossi?
Pete. Uh-
Why are you at my home?
Are you.
Are you what about bobbing me?
What is this? This is.
This is inappropriate.
You're the f****** Scatman. It's you? Pete.
I think you're having a manic,
paranoid episode,
and you're projecting this on to me.
That's bulls***.
How come the user had an LLC agreement
attached to this address?
Okay, okay, fine!
Did you sign, yes!
Bravo, Pete.
Bravo. You caught me.
Congratulations.
Light up your pipe, Sherlock Holmes.
Because this one's in the books. What is this?
Why do you have a glaive?
Have you come to kill me?
What are you doing, Pete?
I don't know, man.
I'm really f****** confused.
Why don't we go inside
and have a little chat about this?
Free of charge.
Put the weapon
down, and let's just have a little chat.
Why would you do this to me?
You know how triggering and f****** traumatic this is?
Look Pete, I thought you would have figured
this out by now,
but clearly, it's
just not getting through to you.
You don't see what this is?
I am helping you, Pete.
This is all part of our treatment.
What are you talking about?
All this work you're doing, you're
obsessing over this Wikipedia picture.
You know what that tells me, Pete?
It tells me that you're not doing
very good at all.
I mean, Pete, this is just my way
of tracking you or controlling you.
You know, but, like,
I'm trying to keep tabs on
if you're making any progress, and,
god damn it, you have failed!
What kind of method is that?
What kind of therapy is that?
I don’t have to explain myself to you.
You sound like all the rest of them.
They all say, "oh, you're crazy"
"You're methods are impractical,
inhumane, ineffective"
"They won't work"
"They're not based in science"
And you know what I say, shut your- shut your mouth! You stupid Harvard a******!
I'm not even a college trained therapist and I know more than you.
You don’t have a college degree?
What does that matter?
I have to have a little plaque on my wall
for you to feel good?
Okay? Yeah.
Okay.
So now you’re fixating on what other people have.
Oh. Oh,
this guy's got a nicer car than me.
This guy has
an actual professional therapist.
I got to have what he has.
My goodness.
We're going to have a lot
to talk about on Thursday, pal.
You don’t think it's weird
that I pay a guy to talk about a guy
who's fucking with my head,
and it's the same f****** guy? Not at all.
You know what?
I'm going
to have to have a whole other session
with you and walk you through this, okay?
How's your Tuesday?
I'm going to pencil you in for that.
You're an idiot.
I'm leaving.
No, dude.
Pete, I get it. Okay.
You're frustrated.
This is a lot to process, so.
All right, well, I will pencil you in
for Tuesday, and we are good.
No, you're fired.
Not even on Thursday.
I'm never going to see you again.
I've already put you in, so I'm going
to have to charge you if I cancel.
But I didn't make the appointment!
it’s less than 24 hours.
And that’s just the rule.
You're fired. Okay, Pete.
Is this about the photo?
Yes.
Okay, I'll take the stupid photo down
if you're so fixated on it
but I’m not going to give up on you.
I don't quit on my patients, Pete.
I don't give up on them.
Not until the day they die.
And they all die.
Most of them have. Suicide.
Mostly.
Not all of them.
You're here.
Oh, my God.
You did the fake death announcement, too,
didn't you?
Well, I guess we’ll never know.
F*** you.
Unless you stop caring about the things
that don't matter. Pete!
All this time and energy
you spent focusing on this...
you could have spent that, focusing
on the things
that are really important to you, Pete.
What matters in your life, Pete?
Amy,
your mom,
your mother.
Peter?
Peter, where are you?
Oh, my God.
F***, you’re good.
No s***, Pete.
See you on Thursday?
Can you do Friday?
Actually, I have a thing. I forgot.
I have a thing on Thursday.
I can do Zoom. Do you do Zoom?
Zoom is fine. I'll be in my car.
If that’s not an issue.
No, it's cool.
Okay, I'll see you then, bud.
Pete.
Yeah?
Don't forget your weapon.
Oh, yeah.